a CBS News poll out this morning shows
president Trump's approval rating is at
36% it is his lowest point in our
polling since he took office his
approval has dropped among Republicans
72% approve of the job he's doing down
from 83% after his first 100 days CBS
News elections and survey director
Anthony selves on so is here Anthony
always good to see you how are you well
thank you very much so let's talk about
the Russia investigation first what do
we learn in this poll about the
president's well that's what's weighing
down is overall job approval numbers and
we know that because folks give lower
ratings to him on handling that issue
than they do want anything else and that
it's lower than what he gets on the
economy is lower than what he gets on
handling terrorism and that movement
among Republicans is for his handling of
it which is important because it's not
whether or not they support him or
whether or not they like him they don't
think he's doing a good job handling
that and they also say that you know
it's a it's not necessarily a serious
matter and they don't necessarily think
he's done anything wrong it's more a
sense of get to the bottom of it let the
investigation take its course what do
they think about Mitch McConnell
operating without transparency in the
Senate to create a Senate bill on health
care that might be possible yeah there's
this overwhelming number including among
Republicans that say make the bill
public and what happens is when folks
don't know what's going on and they
actually tell us in the poll that they
don't feel they have a good
understanding what's going on which is
rare for people to admit in even in
polling they get cynical about it so by
two-to-one they feel that well they
think this bill will probably hurt them
rather than help them to the extent that
they feel they know about it and so that
there again is why they overwhelmingly
push to say well at least let us know
what it's going to do let's talk about
civility in American politics you they
were asked about that what did you find
there because it seems like most people
blame the other guy yeah there are there
is a core a hard core about 20% of each
party's base that fields the other side
is a threat to their way of life but
that's not the majority majority of
people feel that the other side are just
people they disagree with and could
possibly get along with and even though
Americans say that they feel like the
tone and tenor of politics has gotten
water
over time there is a majority that still
remains optimistic that people can work
things out don't you always here at
civility it's always a worse that's ever
been yeah we do we do often hear that
but that doesn't mean people don't sense
a trend line going down you know I think
the biggest break sometimes we always
see the world in terms of left and right
yeah but the biggest break is really
between those folks who see things in
stark partisan terms and those who do
not thank you in - thank you thanks very
much